um he wasn't the only we heard him on
mike talking to chris webber he wasn't
the only one miked up though here's
deandre jordan
tonight we celebrate the life and legacy
of dr barbara king jr
we stand here together community
continuing his work
on creating a better tomorrow thank you
stay safe
[Applause]
[Music]
good job fiorello good job
oh
some
[Music]
biggest takeaway from that game besides
that the biggest takeaway from
brooklyn's win
over milwaukee hey before we go to the
next highlight don't don't go to the
next highlight yet
come back to us what the heck are you
two guys doing over here
we had i had a question for chuck sure
so chuck
if you work with it get out
and oh i got oh you guys are using the
same
deandre yeah
do you see this motion fiorello fiorello
you know what he's doing
hey he already he already cut your mic
[Music]
hey your mic your mic's not on man your
mic is not on
hey listen up
intentionally intentionally sabotaging
the audio
in studio jay
you said what i'm doing oh he's going to
shoot the ball
then he's going to pass it he's going to
play
steve fiorello getting a twitter mention
fiorella watching the andre
hey how about san antonio in portland
shall we do that amen
[Laughter]
oh he sort of know being bad
oh my god
[Music]
oh we're back uh oh
even better with no sound hey tiny rick
rick why they call you tight
yeah we don't want to go there we go